for the Prime Minister flanked by his
Home Secretary and the Met Police
Commissioner it was a sobering visit to
London Bridge his predecessors have had
to deal with the aftermath of previous
terrorist attacks this the first major
terrorist incident in more than two
years and the first under Boris
Johnson's watch one of the two people
who died has been named as Cambridge
University graduate jack merritt mr.
Merrit was a course coordinator at
learning together which held the prison
rehabilitation conference attended by
the attacker on Friday afternoon that
attack began inside the venue before
spilling out onto London Bridge in the
chaos and confusion members of the
public put their own lives at risk to
confront the armed attacker we saw some
wonderful examples of professionalism of
quick thinking and of course of
compassion and
it's a terrible thing that people found
themselves in that position but as we
saw the worst of humankind we also saw
the very best of human spirit the
attacker was 28 year old Guzman Khan a
convicted terrorist who plotted with
eight others to carry out Al
qaeda-linked attacks on targets
including the London Stock Exchange he
was jailed for those offences but
released from prison last December and
fitted with the GPS enabled electronic
tag still considered a risk to the
public
this was Khan interviewed in 2010 at the
end of a police investigation and to him
and others he spoke then of a deep
mistrust of the authorities now I know I
can never ever trust him never ever I
didn't trust him them anyway any book
now they've shown the hatred you've
showed how much they can hate you there
are legitimate questions still to be
answered was who's man Khan released
from prison too early was he properly
monitored but for now the focus for
investigators here is on the wider
threat are there other people out there
who knew what this man was planning
detectives have spent the day searching
newsmen cans Holman Stafford as they
pieced together his activities in recent
months they've removed electronic
devices and other items for forensic
examination we found no evidence no
evidence to suggest anybody else was
involved in this attack however we're
still making extensive inquiries to
ensure that no one else was involved
Guzman Conn was an associate of the
extremest Anjem Choudary as a member of
a group affiliated to Choudhary's band
Alma Hodge Aroon organization he
attended rallies and protests in the
Midlands I think we need an urgent risk
assessment remember those men was one of
nine individuals who'd committed I was
committed and found guilty of plotting
to blow apart on excite you know what is
happening to those other individuals
there they're out and about how they be
monitored are we confident that they are
being monitored effectively at the scene
of the attack the area remains sealed
off the capital's mayor praised the
spirit and resolve of Londoners who he
said were determined to get back to
normal life as quickly as possible
Barra Marquis is even our bars and
restaurants are full of people enjoying
the food and enjoying the sights and
sounds of our city was very important
don't allow this terrorist to stop us
from enjoying the next few weeks and
heat up to Christmas
as people begin the sadly all too
familiar process of paying their
respects at the scene the Queen has sent
a message
expressing her sadness and praising the
bravery of those members of the public
who rushed forward in the face of great
danger to disarm the attacker mark white
Sky News well let's just remind you of
the key events as they unfolded
yesterday the attack began at
fishmongers hall where a cambridge
university backed conference on prison
education was taking place police say
that Khan left the building and headed
to London Bridge that's where he was
when they were called at 1:58 p.m. to
reports of a stabbing a number of videos
on social media show Khan being wrestled
to the ground by a group of bystanders
and confronted by police at 2:03 p.m. he
was shot and killed
he had a hoax explosive device strapped
to his chest Sky News has seen video of
a person receiving CPR closeby at a
monument and while this was happening
people were evacuated from Borough
Market on the south side of London
Bridge a white police cordon is now in
place on both sides of the River Thames
officers at the Met Police
counterterrorism unit are leading the
investigation